this entire spying program has been done
in secret and it was done intentionally
and and the electorate the people of the
country have been kept in the dark
they've been lied to and and basically
manipulated to accept the narrative
coming out of the White House and the
intelligence community this is bill
Binney
he's a former employee of the NSA turned
whistleblower now he's speaking out
about how the agency he used to work for
is spying on Americans a lot of people
are feel fearful that down the line we
could become 1984 we could become the
ultimate surveillance state to what
extent are we already that in the night
we passed that a long time ago how so
yeah well I mean 1984 just looked at
visual things you know they just watch
where you're going on now not only we're
doing that we're looking at seeing what
you're saying what you're while you're
doing it right and seeing where you're
going and what's your what you're all
about whether or not to have medical
problems or or legal problems or
anything like that any kind of
influences that might affect you but
it's also looking at your community you
know you and who you're collaborating
with and maybe what you're collaborating
on and also what you're planning and
also getting into how you think because
after you after you accumulate a lot of
data about a person in there their
activities throughout day to day in
their life you can begin to understand
how they think about things and you can
begin to predict how they'll react in
some cases a lot of people believe
nothing to fear nothing to hide what do
you say to those people and what's the
danger of that mentality I only had well
I only have two things to say to them
the first one is that's a great quote
from Joseph kerbals he said exactly the
same thing Hitler's minister of
propaganda and the second thing is that
what what you think about what you're
doing is totally irrelevant you do not
matter in the equation you're you're not
important the only important thing is
what the government thinks of you and
what you're doing now what do you think
when you look at the younger generation
now that basically completely broadcasts
every moment on their of their lives on
social media on various platforms
Facebook Instagram Twitter snapchat what
do you say to those young people and
what should they be thinking of down the
line what would I say to them I would
say first of all don't do it don't put
your information
they're like that because you can ever
it's out there permanently so that when
an employer wants to research what
you've said and done on Facebook or any
place else that that's available for
them to look at so it could influence
whether or not you get a job you know
what the kinds of the kind of activity
you're permitted to engage in that kind
of thing so that's very dangerous stuff
you should not do that I mean anything
you put out there you should assume that
it is now going to be visible by
everybody in the public what can we as
private citizens do to take a stand
against domestic spying every time a
representative or from the house or a
senator comes to have a town meeting in
your area to solicit your vote that you
need to stand up and embarrass them and
make sure and put them on the spot what
are you doing about this spying why
aren't you stopping it why aren't you
should say why aren't you living up to
your oath of office to protect and
defend the Constitution and then just
find out what the answer and just push
them and put them out in the spotlight
put them on the spot now that's one way
the other way is to email them call them
twittered Senate Twitter to them it's
the idea of taking it on from many
directions at once you're very vocal
when it comes to speaking out against
the NSA to what extent are you fearful
no I don't care I'm out here I have one
purpose in life I only have so much time
left my by my time is going to be spent
going after them so they'll start doing
the right thing again and we can get our
country back what grade do you give
President Obama who is a constitutional
law professor himself when it comes to
you know privacy and data collection all
these things were talking about if I
give him an F he's an absolute failure
and at defending he is his oath of
office is to preserve protect and defend
the Constitution and he's not doing any
of that he he and all of those people
down down in Congress are violating the
public trust that's the that's the trust
we put in them with them and give them
to do the right thing how do you compare
him to his predecessor George W Bush
actually he's doubling down on what
George Bush did so I think he's doing
I mean George Bush wanted to capture
terrorists so he could torture them and
get information Obama simply wants to
kill them and anybody that comes close
to them with drone strikes